Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number that
you should feel more than welcome to call
any time of day.
That number is two one nine two, David.
Here's a good question.
Asking about about whatever became of the
Andrew Cuomo scandal in New York.
Speaker 8: Hi, David.
Quick question for you.
Why are we hearing anything more about Andrew
Cuomo is.
Every day a couple of weeks ago, this allegation
after allegation, new woman coming out saying
that he did something inappropriate.
Now.
Don, I know this is another on the long line
of news stories that has dried up into the
ether.
What's your take on it?
Speaker 1: My take is not that different than
what's been going on with Matt Gates, which
is the Matt Gates story has also sort of taken
a backseat.
I think that there are these kind of lulls
where not LULAC, right.
LULAC, to be clear, we learn about an investigation
and then there's a period where the investigation
is happening.
And unless there's something to keep the story
in the news, corporate media just lets it
go.
And my expectation is that when this all gets
closer to a conclusion or there is some some
final determination and I'm talking both about
Matt Gates, whether there will be charges
and the investigation into Andrew Cuomo, that
it'll be back in the news.
I think it's that simple.
There's other shiny objects that corporate
media has moved on to.
We will talk about the task of fact checking
Joe Biden on today's bonus.
Joe Kröger will also be starting drone deliveries
in Ohio this week.
What will it how will it look?
What will it look like?
How will it work?
And also, the United States has started to
reunite some families separated at the Mexico
border.
We will tell you how it's being done and what
we can expect.
Plus, much more, including producer parts,
full fallout from vaccination dose number
two, which he received yesterday morning,
yesterday in the morning.
All of that and more on today's bonus show.
Don't miss it.
Get a membership at join Pakman Dotcom to
get into
the access.
And I
will
see y